>>> WE ARE LEARNING WHAT CRUISE
SHIPS COULD BE LIKE WHEN THEY
SET SAIL AGAIN IN AMERICAN
WATERS.
PASSENGER SHIPS HAVE NOT BEEN
ALLOWED TO SAIL IN THIS COUNTRY
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR BECAUSE OF,
YOU KNOW, COVID.
THAT'S WIPED OUT MORE THAN
100,000 AMERICAN JOBS.
THIS WEEK, THE CDC SAID THAT
CRUISES COULD POTENTIALLY,
POTENTIALLY RETURN THIS SUMMER
WITH SOME RESTRICTIONS.
FIRST ON "CBS THIS MORNING,"
ERROLL BARNETT SPOKE TO THE CEO
OF ROYAL CARIBBEAN ABOUT THE
COMPANY'S PLANS TO RESTART
OPERATIONS.
>>> WE WANT TO GET OURSELVES
GOING --
>> Reporter: IN HIS FIRST
SIT-DOWN INTERVIEW SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN, ROYAL
CARIBBEAN'S CEO RICHARD FAIN
TELLS CBS NEWS HE'S PUSHING TO
SET SAIL AGAIN NOW THAT THERE'S
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF COVID.
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE CDC TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO THAT IN A SAFE AND HEALTHY
WAY.
>> Reporter: NO CRUISE SHIP WITH
PASSENGERS HAS LEFT A U.S. PORT
IN OVER A YEAR.
LAST FEBRUARY, A MAJOR COVID
OUTBREAK ON BOARD THE "DIAMOND
PRINCESS," RUN BY A SEPARATE
CRUISE COMPANY, LEFT PASSENGERS
STUCK AT SEA FOR NEARLY A MONTH.
SOON AFTER, THERE WAS ANOTHER
OUTBREAK ON BOARD THE "GRAND
PRI
PRINCESS."
IN ALL, MORE THAN 800 WERE
INFECTED WITH COVID AND MORE
THAN A DOZEN PEOPLE DIED.
IN MID-MARCH, THE CDC ISSUED A
NO-SAIL ORDER, STOPPING ALL
CRUISES FROM THE U.S.
>> I'VE DONE FOUR CRUISES SINCE
COVID APPEARED, AND I WILL BE
DOING ANOTHER ONE VERY SOON.
>> Reporter: BUT CRUISES HAVE
RESUMED ELSEWHERE.
MORGAN O'BRIEN IS AN AMERICAN
TRAVEL VIDEO BLOGGER LIVING IN
GERMANY.
>> ON BOARD THE SHIP WE ARE
REQUIRED TO WEAR A SURGICAL MASK
AT ANY TIME WE'RE MOVING AROUND
THE SHIP.
>> Reporter: AND VIDEOS LIKE
THESE, HE'S PUSHING THE CDC TO
ESTABLISH PROTOCOLS CRUISE SHIPS
OUTSIDE THE U.S. ARE ALREADY
USING.
>> PEOPLE ARE GETTING
TEMPERATURE CHECKS EVERY DAY.
WE HAVE TO BE TESTED 72 HOURS
BEFORE THE CRUISE LEAVES.
OF COURSE, IT HAS TO BE A
NEGATIVE PCR TEST.
>> Reporter: ROYAL KRAB HAS
TESTED THOSE -- CARIBBEAN HAS
TESTED THOSE SYSTEMS ABOARD WITH
ENCOURAGING RESULTS.
>> THE ROYAL CARIBBEAN GROUP HAS
CARRIED OVER 100,000 GUESTS.
OF THAT, WE'VE ONLY HAD TEN
CA
CASES.
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE TREATED IN A
SIMILAR WAY TO THE AIRLINES AND
WERE TRANSPORTATION.
>> Reporter: LAST WEEK THE CDC
UNVEILED TECHNICAL STEPS FOR
CRUISE OPERATORS INCLUDING TRIAL
VOYAGES WITH VOLUNTEERS AND
UPDATING THE DEFINITION OF
COVID-LIKE ILLNESS FOR
REPORTING.
THEY HAVE NOT SET A SPECIFIC
RETURN DATE.
CRUISE LINES ARE ALSO CHOOSING
TO INSTALL BETTER FILTRATION
SYSTEMS TO CLEAN THE AIR.
HERE IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS,
SHOULD THEY BE ABLE TO SET SAIL,
WHAT WILL BE DIFFERENT?
>> ALL THE CRUISE LINES ARE
WORKING TOWARD BEST PROTOCOLS.
THAT INCLUDES NEW WAYS OF
CIRCULATING AIR, NEW FILTRATION.
IT INCLUDES CLEANLINESS, WAYS TO
CLEAN AREAS.
IT INCLUDES TESTING.
>> Reporter: THE CDC ALSO
RECOMMENDS PASSENGERS AND CREW
GET VACCINES BEFORE BOARDING.
SOME COMPANIES ARE TAKING IT
FURTHER.
ROYAL CARIBBEAN AND NORWEGIAN
SAY THEY WILL REQUIRE ALL
PASSENGERS AND CREW TO BE
INOCULATED.
>> NOBODY CAN GUARANTEE ANYBODY
IS SAFE FROM COVID ANYWHERE IN
AMERICA OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
ACTUALLY, THE IRONY IS IF YOU GO
ON A SHIP, YOU'RE GOING TO
REDUCE YOUR RISK OF COMING DOWN
WITH THE VIRUS.
>> Reporter: NOW FAIN MAKES THAT
ASSERTION BY SAYING THAT THEY
WILL TEST PASSENGERS BEFORE,
DURING, AND AFTER TRIPS.
THEY WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO
CONTACT TRACE WITH TECHNOLOGY
THEY DESCRIBE AS A TRACER.
A WEARABLE DEVICE, TRACKING
DEVICE.
IT HAS RFID TECHNOLOGY SO THAT
IF THERE IS A POSITIVE CASE ON
BOARD, THEY CAN ISOLATE THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND LET YOU KNOW IF
YOU'VE COME ANYWHERE NEAR THEM
WITHIN SIX FEET.
REALLY IMPRESSIVE STUFF.
NOW THE VESSEL YOU SEE BEHIND
ME, THIS HUGE THING, CAN CARRY
UP TO 4,500 PEOPLE.
THE CRUISE INDUSTRY WANTS TO SET
SAIL AGAIN HERE IN THE U.S. BY
JULY.
BUT OF COURSE, THE CDC HAS NOT
PERMITTED THAT JUST YET.
AND I KNOW, TONY, YOU ARE A FAN
OF THESE HUGE VESSELS.
YOU'RE AMONG 15 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO WOULD HAVE GONE ON
A CRUISE IN THIS PAST YEAR.
AND INSTEAD THAT NUMBER HAS BEEN
ZERO.
>> I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED THAT.
I WAS GOING TO SAY THAT BOAT
LOOKS INVITING TO ME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M ROOTING FOR THE CRUISE
INDUSTRY NOT ONLY BECAUSE
100,000 PEOPLE WORK IN IT BUT
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING LIKE
BEING OUT ON THE OPEN OCEAN AND
NOT SEEING LAND.
IT REALLY ALTERS YOUR VIEW OF
THE WHOLE PLANET.
>> I'VE BEEN ON A COUPLE OF
CRUISE -- HOLLAND AMERICA AND
ROYAL CARIBBEAN, TO NAME A
COUPLE.
I THINK IT'S GREAT FOR FAMILIES
BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING FOR ALL
AGES.
YOU'RE ALL IN ONE AREA.
YOU CAN COME AND GO AS YOU
PLEASE.
SO I THINK MR. FAIN MAKES A GOOD
POINT.
OF THE 100,000 HE SAID --
>> 100,000 PASSENGERS, ONLY TEN
CASES.
>> THAT IS VERY APPEALING --
>> GOOD NEWS.
I HOPE MY WIFE IS WATCHING.
SHE HOLDS THE SWING VOTE IN OUR
HOUSEHOLD.
SHE'S CURRENTLY NO --
>> AS SHY SE SHOULD.